hélène buzzati pour journée christian
dufour bonsoir au soir dans on va parler
des rassemblements illégaux dans une
seconde mais d'abord revenons sur les
voyages on ne sait toujours pas quand
sera annoncée on pense c'est demain en
conseil des ministres n on y reviendra
mais là entre temps aujourd'hui
engueulades à la chambre des communes
ont je vous montre deux tweets un pablo
rodriguez claude gérard deltell pablo
rodriguez qui crie incroyable et
opposition bloc de projet de loi qui
interdit les 1000 dollars aux gens qui
doivent s'isoler apprend voyage d'un
essentiel ça c'est le fameux mille
dollars qu'on avait tant dénoncées dans
les vacances de noël il avait pourtant
réclamé la deltell répond incroyable
aussi en septembre on n'a eu qu'une
journée pour débattre du c4 quelconque
chasse et erreur aujourd'hui il refuse
le débat bon alors et l'âne est claire
et nous on croyait tout le monde
s'entendait pour annuler les 1000
dollars qu'on allait donner aux gens
qu'ils allaient revenir mais là on
s'entend plus mais sur le plan de
l'image je pense que ça fait mal
paraître les partis d'opposition parce
qu'ils ont l'air de mettre les grains de
sable dans l'engrenage alors que tout le
monde s'attendait que c'était une faille
qu'il fallait colmater mais sur le fond
il faut quand même reconnaître que ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui donc les
partis d'opposition ont refusé de donner
leur consentement pour que moi je crois
qu'ils auraient réglé le problème soit
adoptée dans une même journée donc on
escamote tout processus parlementaire
dans les faits ça changera pas grand
chose parce que il y a deux semaines de
ça déjà le gouvernement avait changé le
processus pour faire une demande de
cette fameuse prestations de maladie
vous deviez déclaré si votre quarantaine
à laquelle vous devez vous soumettre
était le fruit d'un voyage et si vous
disiez oui et bien on me demande
elle était suspendue elle ne serait pas
très en vue mais le dollar a déjà que
son talent à cancun pour alors ça
changera rien ça changera vraiment
enrayer le blocage d'aujourd'hui et il
faut quand même reconnaître que
l'opposition a soulevé un point
intéressant c'est que le projet de loi
qui était prévue aujourd'hui qu'on a
quand même pas vu vous le précisions ont
été déposés et est rétroactif au 3
janvier
est-ce que l'opposition dit ces cas où
ben oui mais
les gens qui ont voyagé puis sont venus
le 28 et le 29 le 30 décembre pourrait
encore se qualifier la prestation dont
on referme pas totalement là on va
devenir fou et les voyages paul là par
ailleurs on attend demain
enfin on attend demain on ne sait pas si
demain et la naspe ah non en fait j'ai
fermé mon téléphone mais jusqu'à présent
il n'avait pas d'alibi
bientôt on attend des nouvelles mesures
est-ce qu'on va obliger les gens qui
vont voyager en quarantaine paul vous en
êtes où dans tout ça québec attend sorte
quoi oui puis les attentes
le souhait de québec si on interdisait
les voyages non essentiels le
gouvernement legault serait très content
mais il y avait une situation de
compromis du genre imposer une
quarantaine à l'arrivée avant le camp
quand la personne ne touche le sol
au canada lui administrer en vitesse etc
la quarantaine soit assez frais et sous
surveillance policière je pense que le
gouvernement doit aussi très très
satisfaits moins de questions je me
posez c'est est ce que le québec et les
autres provinces auraient les ressources
policières pour surveiller la
quarantaine parce que bien que quelqu'un
la surveille et on dit que oui sûrement
qu il y aurait moyen de trouver une
solution mais bon pour québec s'est pas
trop compliqué on demande au fédéral de
régler le problème mais dans le détail
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et un peu
en fait le revers de ce qu'on voit dans
la gestion des ch et celle d aceh
terrain où le fédéral dit aux provinces
soutenir votre travail mais eux ils
comprennent pas trop trop les aspects
très complexe sur un horizon jamais eu à
gérer ça mais le cycle des provinces
avec le fédéral mais la dernière chose
que je dirais c'est qu'il faut pas
oublier que du point de vue mais des
problèmes le fédéral et scientifique
c'est la question du brillant je
comprends que les voyageurs ne compte
pas pour une si grande proportion des
corps mais si on s'intéresse
particulièrement heureux c'est par
crainte que le mais les variants
arrivent au québec
ok christian wahl je trouve qu'on est
rendus loin
et policiers qui m'ont surveillé les
voir parce que je trouve que il faut le
dire le des policiers qui vont
surveiller la quarantaine de citoyens
canadiens qui ont contrevenu à aucune
loi
moi ça me choque beaucoup on n'est pas
juste en fait dans la rationalité là
dedans je comprends qu'il ne va rien je
comprends qu'il ya les amis qui
sanitaires officielles
mais c'est un dossier où il ya beaucoup
de charriage un manque de rigueur
incroyable il ya un peu je dirais de
démocrates attraper un moyen beaucoup de
démagogie là dedans comme vous l'avez
dit patrick patrice excusez moi je
source c'est après 1 à 2% en fait des
codes contamination les gens qui sont
partis et on l'a jamais des boucs
émissaires qui s'applique
on est quand même dans un domaine où on
touche aux droits fondamentaux moi je
dois dire que depuis deux 2 semaines
j'étais estomaqué de voir beaucoup de
commentateurs d'éditorialistes de
chroniqueurs qui d'habitude en fait à
part toujours la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés en rapport avec des
thèmes qui samba si frivole puis dans ce
dossier là ils ont demandé et exigé que
le gouvernement suspende au plus sacrant
le droit des calaisiens de partir bon
voyons prouesse que j'en suis mon modèle
d'armée dynamique
heureusement je pense que le
gouvernement fédéral ne semble pas
vouloir empêcher les canadiens de sortir
du pays même le président françois
legault semblait résigné à ça moi ce que
je vais surveiller est ce qu'on est
vraiment dans ce jeu dynamique sanitaire
j'ai pas de problème avec les dynamiques
sanitaire avec les variants rappelant
que les variants sont déjà rendus pour
une bonne partie au canada mais si un
dynamique vindicative pour punir des
canadiens qui ont contrevenu aucune loi
si on veut faire indirectement ce qu'on
n'est pas capable de faire directement
moi j'espère que ça va être contestée
devant les tribunaux
ça va être annulé on est quand même dans
un état de droit où qu'elle adore oui
mais où
d'où la nuance sur les chiffres quand je
dis quelque chose christian di cule en
reportant déco viennent des voyageurs
c'est parmi les codes dont les causes
sont connues mais au québec le 2 août
pour le deux tiers des cas on ne sait
pas d'où ils viennent donc bon ça c'est
quand même une nuance le qui pourrait
porter à croire que le rôle des
voyageurs même si pas à la majorité dont
l'objet est plus qu elle dit christian
vous avez vous admettrez paul qu'on
n'est pas juste dans l'objectif le
rigoureux
le silence se fait que aussi autre chose
là dedans je sais que c'est massif la
population canadienne qui est traumatisé
en fait enfin une fixation là dessus les
gouvernements et hélène les hits pour
toutes sortes de raisons parce qu'ils
auraient les instruments juridiques pour
le faire dit il prend vent des
contestations mais le gouvernement
fédéral aurait toutes les lois qu'il
veut pour imposer sa s'il voulait comme
la belgique l'a fait comme d'autres
l'ont fait d ilan est ce que vous y
voyez aussi autre chose qu'une logique
sanitaire
c'est comme si les l'opinion publique
est tellement furieuse de voir des gens
partir au soleil
alors que tout le monde fait des efforts
que ça devient il ya un côté qui devient
irrationnel totalement écoutez je chute
à je suis d'accord qu'il ya une sativa
dit que les sondages nous montre un 60
80 % des gens demandent que les voyages
sont interdits tentons nord-sud
courriels de lecteurs nous qu'on disait
pourquoi met-on pas un bracelet gps aux
voyageurs à leur bateau comme ça on
pourrait s'assurer que ne transgresse
pas leur quarantaine ça vous donne une
idée de où seront vendus
certaines personnes ils sont fâchés des
leaf russe des délimitations qu'ils
vivent en ce moment sont furieux mais il
faut comprendre que ce 1 ou 2% le dont
on parlait tout à l'heure si ce qui
explique pourquoi ottawa autant tardé à
agir là dessus parce que ce qu'on leur
dit c'est que les efforts à déployer
pour soit empêché les voyageurs de
partir ou alors de les contrôler à leur
retour serait peut-être démesuré par
rapport aux gains sanitaire qui en
serait retiré quand
choisissez la santé publique canadienne
ouais c'est ça system is ready bon autre
chose qui a choqué en fin de semaine
parlant de vague de colère c'est ces
rassemblements illégaux chez les juifs
hassidiques à outremont à montréal je
vous faire entendre le porte parole qui
a une heure et demie est venu
s'expliquer en dix ans dans le fond les
règles étaient pas clair dit-il
on est connu comme je dire nous sommes
tous poussés dans un coin c'est un jour
triste
ici au québec quand nous devrons
expliquer pourquoi le droit d'acheter
d'alcool de cannabis est plus protégé
que le droit des prières de façon
sécuritaire
donc nous sommes en discussion avec nos
avocats
on a le on a le courriel qu'envoyer la
santé publique en disant on s'excuse
parce qu'on avait peut-être
effectivement permis dix personnes par
le local à une même adresse
dans ces lieux et non pas 10 personnes
pour une adresse là ces dix personnes
pour une adresse bref beaucoup de gens
de la communauté hassidique se sont ont
pris ça comme prétexte en dire bien
voici pourquoi on a dérogé
mais depuis le début il faut quand même
le dire pas de journée il ya une
réticence
j'ai cette communauté à respecter les
règles c'est le courriel d'un milieu
droit 10 sincèrement pour le va et vient
des dernières 48 heures dispo dix
classes et 10 c clair paul chose il
dans le détail les règles étaient
peut-être pas claire mais est-ce que ça
justifie de traiter les policiers de
nazis piles et les harceler non on voit
que le problème est beaucoup plus
profond
tous les efforts pour combattre la
pandémie au fond peut dire qui dépend de
deux choses en une confiance minimal
dans la science 2 un sens du collectif
que on se tient serré ensemble
solidaires et on comprend que c'est un
moment difficile à traverser
il faut qu'on fasse des efforts pour
protéger les plus vulnérables et je
pense que ces deux choses le manque
complètement et il ya une responsabilité
des leaders de la communauté d'expliquer
la d'expliquer la coved en ce moment ces
graves dans les hôpitaux puis que les
normes elles sont produites ou un de ses
poids des communautés religieuses en
particulier pour les normes intolérante
et donc je pense que vraiment un gros
gros échec et une profonde exaspération
très justifié la barre du spvm par
rapport à ce qu'est le spvm sont le
grand patron a dit ce matin c'est
inacceptable de traiter des policiers de
nazis alors qu'ils font leur travail il
faut quand même revenir sur terre
française est inacceptable mais voilà
christian duffau même dans une situation
normale les relations avec cette commune
communauté le sursaut difficile
bon on est en face en fait d'une secte
juive qui radical se sont pas tous les
juifs qui sont comme ça et en fin de
semaine d'après les informations que
j'ai recueillis c'est une frange
radicale de la secte radicale qui s'est
exprimé on touche à quelque chose de
très délicat on n'est pas dans le dire
dans le rationnel on est dans
l'irrationnel
on voit que
gagnon représentant qu'ils aient pour
nous c'est impossible de ne pas prier
c'est pas négociable de prix et donc une
forme d'extrémisme l'acda en même temps
dès qu'on touche au phénomène juif il ya
toujours le souvenir de leur bloc
tout ça est très très délicat et empiré
par la pandémie c'est vrai que de
traiter les policiers de juifs c'est pas
quand même saisir et c'est que ça se
calme ça se calme ça se calme mais c'est
un autre exemple
même dans la situation normale il ya des
gens et des communautés qui sont plus ou
moins fonctionnel fait imaginer ce que
ça devient dans le contexte actuel
hélène un petit mot oui fondamentalement
c'est cette priorité absolue donnée au
fait religieux qui est agaçant la 2g
coûté la halle aux commentaires du porte
parole le sophisme absolue de parler de
marijuana d'alcool et de religion là
dedans
lorsqu'on va acheter de l'alcool la
dernière fois je suis allé ont fait la
file et on rentre un après l'autre on
n'est qu'à un troupeau il ya comme un
refus de reconnaître que la religion
doit être soumise elle aussi a ses
règles sanitaires dans cette situation
absolument exceptionnel et c'est agaçant
de voir que la communauté refuse de
reconnaître quelque chose d'aussi de
base oui et oui c'est ça
c'est le refus des règles du jeu
collective autour d'eux c'est comme ça
n'existait pas dans ce cas aussi parce
que à 8 heures depuis deux semaines à 8
heures on me dit que ces arrêtés mais on
faisait aller les claques sont les
sirènes à 8 heures pour protester contre
le couvre feu
là bas donc il ya quand même des voisins
qui étaient pas contents aussi c'est ça
montre qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire effectivement pour
établir des ponts mais peut-on le faire
bay ont fait des jeux les efforts pour
rétablir dépend en fait dans les
dernières années mais on vient tous
collectivement de reculer parce que
l'impression que ça donne c'est que soi
que la communauté ne comprends pas
qu'elle est en train de faire payer le
prix aux réseaux la société ou qu'elle
le sait et qu'elle s'en fout parce
qu'elle croit que pratique religieuse
les autres prisons considération
christian conclusions rapidement oui je
suivrai pas trop focaliser sur la
communauté juive
partout dans le monde le cataclysme
convient crée des situations on n'aurait
jamais pu imaginer pense aux pays bas on
appris aujourd'hui que les pays bas pays
pacifique s'il en est un bon il ya des
espèces de troubles de révolte contre
les consignes contre le couvre feu donc
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres convient
et je trouve que pour faire attention de
focaliser trop exclusivement très bien
merci à vous trois ans on se reparle
merci beaucoup on atteint ce qui est
rare conférence de presse hellène de
même monsieur trudeau à suivre y'a pas
de communiquer qui sortira
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit